in soweto like the rest of haute
province cases of the omicron variant
are soaring
rising faster in fact than they did in
previous waves including the highly
infectious delta
a worrying sign
probably 50 of the samples that we're
testing on our positive so it feels like
in the space of a week maybe 10 days we
went from nothing to
huge amounts of positives it's very
scary actually when we're doing the
analysis
we didn't see that sort of increase when
we were during delta or beta or during
the second and third wave it's
definitely this one it's it's taken off
like we haven't seen before
south africa is one of the continent's
leaders when it comes to vaccination but
they've immunized not even a quarter of
their population
in the uk we've done nearly everyone and
are now offering boosters to all
a strategy that the who has now openly
questioned for the first time it's tough
for some countries who have
huge amounts of xx vaccine to decide who
would give it to but that's not the
problem been faced by a lot of countries
around the world who can't get even
primary vaccination to their most
vulnerable so it's a luxurious position
to be in
if you're in a position to be able to
have enough vaccine to to to do that
right now
there is no evidence
that i'm aware of that would suggest
that
boosting the entire population is going
to necessarily provide any greater
protection for otherwise healthy
individuals against hospitalization or
death many uk health officials might
disagree with cases here averaging more
than 40 000 a day and many over 40 still
needing a booster but the who's
criticism didn't end there travel bans
punish economies and could make
countries less likely to report new
variants certainly if there is any
disincentive if countries feel like they
will be penalized for reporting that
information that is of course a worry
for us
we um you know rely
on this information quite frankly um and
we need to
somehow figure out that all of us are
either in this together or we're not you
cannot have a pandemic in part of the
world and not in others
a point not lost on south africa's
president on a visit to nigeria
these bands must be
removed they must be lifted
because
you do not try and contain
virus through imposing
bans unscientifically and
indiscriminately in fact we should be
applauded as south africa for having
alerted the world
about this variant
that is now beginning to spread around
the world the world is watching and
waiting to see if this latest variant is
worse than what's come before but until
everyone has had a vaccine others will
come along soon enough
tom clark sky news